the girag an experience back at their
time two of my brothers were teaching at
the Gracie school in Carson was Hagen
and Carlos and I think about that time
Chuck Norris is no longer training with
Harlan at the Gracie school they're not
sure what happened and his top training
then one day some of the some Czech
noise show up at our house at our garage
which to teach in our garage in Redondo
Beach and we opened the door Stanley
look is like man that guy looks like
Chuck Norris Candace Chinna was a him
this is Chuck Norris and we look like
what and he brought him to Train he did
train a few years back at the Gracie
School in Babylon it's a long story then
he sat train of us and when he start
raining fires we become very good
friends it was amazing like something
right away he invited us to his house
and he's a great guy me an amazing
persister hanging out and by that time I
remember his to make a movie one movie a
year he worked for six months make a
movie and he has six months off when we
met him he was six months off literally
he trains every day but when he trained
he doesn't go home we have lunch he
hangs out got your movie they suddenly
become good friends then one day he
after a few months after train office he
invited us to the valley where he used
to live in and soon and said look I have
surprise for you guys
then he took us to a shopping center
right on Ventura Boulevard and he shows
a have a gift for you guys and he shows
us a one of the unities mats red is like
a school then he said look this is for
you guys that's your school then we look
at to him like Ventura Boulevard run on
the streets I said check I don't think
we can afford that is there none don't
worry that's my building you guys have
to pay anything I just want to make sure
I don't have to drive there one on one
and four or five drive the Redondo Drive
and he gave this school to us
things like what can I do more about his
life
that's no and that's why we have this
school in the valley because he used to
live in Encino
the school was in Encino then we stuck
coming here then here we do Hogan
Tarzan came by to our school yeah that's
amazing wow what a great guy but the
point on that a conversation was that
our school when we opened our schools to
call Carlos Gracie jiu-jitsu because of
our uncle because when we can mean we
have the gracious Queen I remember the
famous big and everybody has your side
of story everybody's saying something
about your uncle your cousin and we want
to make sure that this side of him that
we were representing away with Carlos
side then a lot of people wonder with
did the grand opening Chuck Norris were
with us doing the self-defense and
demonstration in the grand opening of
the school and that was on Sunday on
Monday were not even ready for the
amount of people that show up at our
school and we have a small place with
the amount of people but a lot of people
start calling the other school asking
where our school work because we're not
even on the the book yeah we are not
even on that and people calling the
other schools hey do you know where the
other school is and they're create a
little situation back there
and we got some calls from all the
cousins and they say hey you guys can I
use the name for the first time living
using the name of our family we realize
like what why not
because you don't have the last name it
can use it then for us we grew up
fighting for the family doing everything
for the family we still do nothing
change but then their suggestion was
yeah you can call machado like all the
Grayson name my family was this because
of [ __ ] Ian yes before you was a lawyer
and so he was the one who kind of
copywriter did and wanted to make it was
like trying to sue carlson at one point
but do you know the crazy thing was this
we have one of the students in and as we
learn jujitsu the most important thing
for me as instructor was everybody can
learn how to fight right
how can you translate what you learn on
the mat to implement on your personal
life that's how we learn to use the
impact measures you two has on you to
succeed outside the Academy I know you
can fight but can you fight on your life
outside then is a different ball gets a
lot bigger and a lot harder and we have
a lot of students that came to us when
we have our garage time that change
their life in coincidentally one of the
students happens to be son of the
biggest lawyer in California and we have
no idea because we end up getting sued
by one side the family they don't have
no money we turn to the shin Se guys I
have I'm sorry we're gonna have to leave
so he thought you're gonna close down
school oh yeah
then we had this guy which his father
was very grateful to us show up look I'm
this hotshot lawyer I can represent you
guys like what have managed to pay now
you guys already I owe you because my
son was saved by you guys who is your
son the his son was 21st for quite some
time became very good easy to change his
life around it was a drug addict
now he's uh one of the best yoga
instructors out there
jiu-jitsu Robert yeah we go and change
his life and their lawyer protector has
made sure that we stay here fine what's
back then and that was on the test today
for our families we have our difference
back there Minh